si giras una pelota alrededor de un eje y luego de otro, el resultado no es el mismo que hacer las dos rotaciones en orden inverso
hoy en Qiskit en el aula veremos qué tiene que ver esta pelota con los ordenadores cuánticos y uno de los más famosos
principios de la mecánica cuántica: el principio de incertidumbre
bienvenido a Qiskit en el aula, una serie de vídeos donde desglosamos un concepto fundamental que puedes
encontrar en un curso relacionado con la computación cuántica. Cada vídeo viene acompañado de un módulo interactivo enlazado en la
descripción de abajo, así que no dejes de verlo. Hoy hablamos del principio de incertidumbre de Heisenberg. Si
ya lo conocías, puede que también hayas escuchado el viejo chiste de Heisenberg: un día lo pararon mientras conducía y el policía le preguntó:
¿sabes a qué velocidad ibas? Heisenberg respondió: no, pero sé exactamente dónde estoy. Esto resume de alguna manera
el principio de incertidumbre de Heisenberg: no puedes conocer simultáneamente la posición y el momento de una partícula
con precisión perfecta. Se suele escribir así: Delta x por Delta p es mayor o igual
a h/ 2, donde Delta X y Delta P son las
incertidumbres en la posición y el momento, y H es una pequeña constante fundamental de la mecánica cuántica.
Heisenberg formuló esta desigualdad en 1927, cuando imaginaba cómo medir la posición de un electrón. Si
haces rebotar un fotón sobre él para ver dónde está, ese fotón inevitablemente empujaría al electrón y alteraría su
momento. Esto no es solo una afirmación sobre las mediciones que perturban un sistema; nos dice que existen límites fundamentales
a cuánto podemos conocer sobre la naturaleza. Este es un ejemplo de un principio más amplio llamado complementariedad, que
dice que ciertos aspectos de la naturaleza son incompatibles entre sí y no pueden observarse
simultáneamente. Por ejemplo, los objetos cuánticos a veces se comportan como partículas y a veces como ondas,
pero no puedes observar ambos comportamientos al mismo tiempo. La relación de posición y momento de Heisenberg cubría solo una de
muchas parejas de características complementarias. Esta incertidumbre inherente tiene que ver con cómo vemos propiedades como
la posición y el momento en la mecánica cuántica. En lugar de pensar en X y P como variables o propiedades intrínsecas
que cada partícula posee, en la mecánica cuántica la posición y el momento son operadores. No son propiedades de un
sistema, sino cosas que puedes hacer a un sistema. Conocer la posición de una partícula ahora requiere que realices una
operación sobre ese sistema y hagas una medición. Esta operación puede afectar el resultado de otras operaciones
posteriores. Como analogía, piensa en un trozo de madera seca. Tiene muchas propiedades, como su
posición, tamaño y forma. También tiene la propiedad de ser combustible y de flotar en el agua. Si esta madera fuera un
objeto cuántico, estas no serían propiedades que pudieras conocer de antemano. En cambio, decimos que son
observables: cosas que puedes conocer sobre el sistema si realizas alguna operación en él. Así que tendrías que aplicar los operadores de
combustibilidad o flotabilidad, lo que requeriría intentar quemar la madera o meterla en
el agua para ver si flota. El resultado de cada uno de estos operadores depende del orden en que los apliques. Si
primero pruebas la combustibilidad, la madera se convertirá en ceniza y no podrás probar si flota. Pero si pruebas
la flotabilidad primero, estará demasiado mojada para arder. Decimos que los operadores de combustibilidad y
flotabilidad no conmutan: el orden de las operaciones importa. Esto lleva a un límite fundamental
en cuán bien se pueden conocer estos dos observables del trozo de madera, ya que no podemos saber con certeza si es
combustible o flotante sin conocer el contexto de esa medición. Claro que con un trozo de madera real puedes
cortarlo a la mitad y probar ambas propiedades simultáneamente, pero no puedes hacer nada parecido con una partícula cuántica. Esta
analogía con la madera es solo eso, una analogía. La incertidumbre es algo exclusivamente cuántico. X y P tampoco conmutan,
y esta propiedad de no conmutatividad es la que lleva al principio de incertidumbre de Heisenberg. En general, dos operadores cualesquiera
que no conmuten tendrán su propio principio de incertidumbre. La forma general del principio de incertidumbre puede
escribirse así: Delta a por Delta
B es mayor o igual a
la mitad del valor absoluto de a y b, donde
este corchete se llama el
conmutador, y es igual a la diferencia entre aplicar primero a y luego
B, y aplicar primero B y luego a. Estos corchetes angulares
indican que estás calculando lo que se llama el valor esperado de lo que está dentro. Básicamente, si haces la misma
medición muchas muchas veces, el valor esperado es el valor promedio de todas esas mediciones. Hoy
vamos a poner a prueba y verificar este principio de incertidumbre en un ordenador cuántico de IBM. Veremos tres observables diferentes
de un qubit, demostraremos que sus operadores no conmutan y finalmente podremos probar que el
principio de incertidumbre se cumple para estos observables del qubit. Primero, una breve nota sobre una forma útil de visualizar el estado cuántico
de un qubit: puede representarse mediante un vector que apunta a algún lugar en una esfera llamada la esfera de Bloch. Lo traté
en un vídeo anterior que está enlazado en la descripción, pero aquí también te daré un breve resumen. Esta es la
esfera de Bloch. Cada vector se parametriza con dos ángulos: Theta y F.
El estado cero está en el polo norte y el estado uno está en el polo sur. Una superposición igual de 0 y 1 está
en algún lugar a lo largo del ecuador, donde f es igual a la fase relativa entre las dos partes de la
superposición. Así que este estado aquí sería igual
a 1 / < tk2 0 + e a la I 1 donde I es ese
fase cuando medimos un observable del qubit el resultado siempre es una de dos opciones que corresponden a los dos
estados posibles del qubit para el experimento que vamos a hacer vamos a ver tres observables y
sus operadores correspondientes X Y y Z cuando mides cualquiera de estos observables obtienes más uno o
menos uno con una probabilidad para cada uno que depende del ángulo entre el vector del qubit en la esfera de Bloch y
el eje de medición como puedes imaginar Z mide a lo largo del eje Z, X a lo largo de X
e Y a lo largo de Y ahora recuerda que hablamos de observables porque con un sistema
cuántico ya no podemos simplemente saber cosas del sistema sin medirlas
y cada observable tiene una operación correspondiente porque las mediciones requieren operaciones puede no ser obvio pero
resulta que las operaciones llamadas operadores que corresponden a cada uno de estos observables X Y y Z son
rotaciones de Pi alrededor de sus respectivos ejes, por lo que X es una rotación alrededor de X, Y
alrededor de Y y Z alrededor de Z entonces para ver si estos operadores conmutan o no podemos comprobar si las rotaciones
en una esfera conmutan si lo hacen el principio de incertidumbre no se aplicará y podríamos conocer X, Y y Z de un qubit
con precisión perfecta si no conmutan entonces podremos encontrar una nueva relación de incertidumbre para el qubit mira
el punto en esta pelota mientras roto primero alrededor de X y luego alrededor de Y termina
aquí ahora intentémoslo en el orden inverso así que roto primero alrededor de Y y
luego alrededor de X termina aquí entonces definitivamente no conmutan eso significa
que no podemos conocer simultáneamente los valores exactos de X, Y y Z de un qubit tendremos una
relación de incertidumbre omitiremos los detalles aquí pero terminamos con tres relaciones de incertidumbre distintas
así que tenemos Delta x * Delta Y
es mayor o igual que Z, Delta Y, Delta Z es mayor o
igual que X y Delta Z, Delta X mayor o igual
que Y entonces el producto de cualquiera de estas dos incertidumbres siempre es mayor o
igual al valor esperado del tercer observable usemos Qiskit para ver qué
pasa cuando intentamos medir tanto Z como X del estado cero medir Z es fácil, es la llamada base estándar
del ordenador cuántico las mediciones siempre son a lo largo de Z por defecto pero para medir X necesitamos realizar algo llamado
cambio de base básicamente rotar la esfera de Bloch para que X apunte hacia arriba donde Z solía apuntar para hacer esto
usamos un gate Hadamard así que el circuit cuántico completo se verá así medimos en Z, aplicamos el Hadamard
y luego medimos en X si usamos el Sampler primitivo de Qiskit para ejecutar este experimento muchas veces obtenemos
un histograma de resultados de medición que se ve así para la medición en Z
y así para la medición en X entonces como puedes ver medimos el
qubit en el estado cero a lo largo de Z con una certeza de casi el 100% pero
a lo largo de X no sabíamos prácticamente nada sobre el estado del qubit se midió como cero o uno con igual
probabilidad lo que significa que nuestra incertidumbre en X era tan grande como puede ser eso nos da
una idea de este intercambio de incertidumbres pero podemos hacerlo un poco mejor en nuestro ordenador cuántico podemos usar un
primitivo de Qiskit llamado Estimator para encontrar los valores esperados de nuestros observables X, Y y Z y la
incertidumbre en cada uno intentémoslo para el estado que apunta en la dirección X positiva en la esfera de Bloch usaremos el Estimator
para calcular las incertidumbres en X y Z para este estado y el valor esperado de
Y con este estado obtenemos este resultado de Qiskit cuando tomamos el producto de las dos
incertidumbres en X y Y vemos que como era de esperar es mayor que el valor absoluto
del valor esperado de Y pero esto fue solo para un estado particular queremos asegurarnos de que esta desigualdad
se cumpla para todos los estados del qubit así que usemos el Estimator de nuevo pero esta vez le pediremos que escanee los valores de un
parámetro y que encuentre los valores esperados en cada valor del parámetro que le demos aquí el parámetro que queremos
escanear es el ángulo Theta en la esfera de Bloch para comprobar la desigualdad para todos los estados del qubit que se encuentran en
este arco que intersecta el plano XZ cuando hacemos esto obtenemos una gráfica en función del ángulo Theta la curva roja
es el producto de las dos incertidumbres y la curva naranja es el valor esperado de Y como era de esperar
el producto de las incertidumbres en X y Z es mucho mayor que el valor esperado de Y pero eso no era
demasiado difícil de satisfacer la desigualdad porque el valor esperado de Y era muy bajo, era cero para todos los estados en
este arco hagamos un escaneo similar a través de los valores de Theta pero en lugar de escanear en el plano XZ vamos a fijar phi igual a pi/
4 así miramos los estados del qubit que se encuentran en un arco diferente en la esfera aquí vemos que la desigualdad se
pone a prueba un poco más ya que la curva naranja y la curva roja están más cerca pero la roja siempre está por encima de la naranja
y el principio de incertidumbre sigue cumpliéndose todavía no hemos comprobado todos los estados pero con suerte ya estás empezando a entender
la idea hay una incognoscibilidad fundamental sobre cualquiera de los dos aspectos complementarios de un sistema
cuántico incluyendo este qubit que hemos estado usando el principio de incertidumbre nos obliga a afrontar el hecho de que sin importar
cuánto lo intentemos sin importar cuán ingeniosas sean nuestras mediciones nunca sabremos todo con precisión perfecta
no hay forma de evitarlo realmente si no me crees, o incluso si me crees, te desafío a revisar el módulo
enlazado en la descripción e intenta superar el principio de incertidumbre gracias por ver y nos vemos la próxima vez